se consideran una generación sacrificada
es tercera vez que los estudiantes
franceses marchan este mes de enero
antes de la crisis del cód y muchos
financiaban su vida universitaria con
pequeños trabajos pero hoy no hay casi
ofertas lo buscaba en un cinema porque
estudió cine pero las salas están
cerradas y si no trabajo en tiendas de
seguro donde pero no podemos ya que
cierran temprano a causa del toque de
queda un jefe le un cambio teme al
fantasma de un tercer confinamiento la
biblioteca universitaria en la que
trabaja no le paga si está cerrada a
nosotros nos pagan por hora trabajada si
no hacemos nuestras horas no hay salario
si hay un nuevo confinamiento la
biblioteca cerrará nuevamente estaremos
en una situación muy difícil la falta de
ofertas de trabajo también la sintió
esta startup especializada en poner en
contacto a empresas y estudiantes
éramos muy buenos en marketing de calle
y de repente ya no distribuimos más
publicidad hacíamos degustación de
productos en las tiendas hoy ya no
hacemos tampoco hay eventos pero poco a
poco nos adaptamos a las áreas de
trabajo que se han ido reactivando los
centros comerciales y negocios han
reabierto y eso fue como una bomba de
oxígeno exigente otra parte de las
demandas de la startup vino de las
farmacias
rafa estudiante tunecina cursa tercer
año de medicina
la empresa le encontró un trabajo
haciendo test de antígenos que se adapta
perfectamente a sus estudios
me proponen un trabajo y yo soy libre de
aceptar o rechazar la propuesta
[Música]
cuando los test en farmacia comenzaron
yo aproveché la ocasión
la joven empresa realizó también una
encuesta entre los 150.000 estudiantes
de su base de datos un 65% reconoció
estar viviendo graves dificultades
financieras